yeah you're fine to go now chair
okay thank you good afternoon everybody
welcome to
um today's executive meeting item one
on the agenda is um attendances
as i just said before we went live
councillor whitson
is um running slightly late and also
councillor patel but hopefully
other members of the executive are
either with us or
joining us shortly i'm not aware of any
other
apologies so we will move on to item two
are there any declarations of interest
in any of the items on the agenda
no okay so item three
um is the greater manchester spatial
framework it's the
approval of the 2020 gmsf for
consultation i'm going to say at this
stage
and members would expect me to do so
that you're all aware
that we have a specific item at the next
council meeting to discuss this which is
the appropriate time to debate
the item but obviously if members have
questions
on anything within the gmss by all means
feel free to ask them if we do enter
into what is becoming speechless or
debate
i will just move us along because i
think with what we've got coming later
in the month there's clearly a more
appropriate forum
um to do that members know that i don't
say or do that very often
but i think it would be um simply
duplicating what will happen
later in the month if we rehearse those
arguments here
and so that said if i could hand over to
council to the right to introduce the
items
thank you leader today i present to you
the final draft of the greater
manchester spatial framework
and the publication stage of the
document as the executive will be aware
this is the third version of this
document with previous editions
which were both consulted on in 2016 and
2019
despite it getting the majority of the
headlines the planning for house
building within this document is not the
only show in town
house building and meeting our housing
need is an essential part of the plan
but there are other incredibly important
parts of this framework which set out
greater manchester's vision for the
future
the framework provides a vision for an
inclusive economy sustainable employment
more opportunities for people in
deprived areas and a key priority to
deal with gm's
inequalities the plan also sets out an
ambitious vision
for the environment active travel and to
deal with climate
change this includes the hb carbon
neutral by 2028
and a net biodiversity gain of no less
than 10
the gmsf also sets out
policies aims and objectives for other
areas including culture and leisure
health
old people and social care however as
i'm sure my colleagues on the executive
will be happy to comment in these areas
i shall not go into any further detail
at this stage
to put the gmsf into constep into
context
we have a housing crisis in trafford and
across greater manchester
in trafford it is more acute than
anywhere else in gm
to buy a home in trafford you need a
mortgage on average that is
over eight times your salary to rent a
home privately in trafford
you will spend an average 45 percent of
your income on rent
to successfully get social housing in
trafford you will wait on average
eight years and even then you are not
guaranteed to get a home
we cannot carry on like this we cannot
as a society just accept that
unless you're lucky enough to have a
much higher salary than the average
or the bank of mum and dad to hand that
when you reach a time to consider buying
a home
you cannot afford to do so in the
borough that you grew up in
we cannot accept that our most
vulnerable in society
are forced to live in temporary
accommodation for months potentially
years
before they get a social home of their
own
most importantly we cannot in 2020
the year of a health pandemic continue
to see people sleeping rough on our
streets
it is immoral and wrong
the gmsf tackles that head-on but it
does so by taking
a collaborative approach across all 10
gm councils
to take some of the burden from the
likes of trafford and spread it
across gm without the gmsf
on the tory government housing figures
we will be required to provide a further
5000 new homes
on top of what is already set out
the loss of some green belt in
carrington and timperley is
i'm afraid the only option
i'm i'm sure we will get the usual and
expected opposition to this tonight
but i ask where would you find the land
for these homes
we have already reduced the green belt
take by 40 percent since 2016.
of course this includes this labour
administration's decisions to remove the
green belt in flixton
from the gmsf allocation
the tory opposition now completely
reject the gmf
gmsf it seems the tory opposition have
no plan
and no clue how to tackle the housing
crisis in trafford
something we already know that will
create more green
belt that green belt loss is by
rejecting the gmsf
with more uncontrolled development and
application decided by the inspector
not locally by committing
the other major changes from 2016 and
2019
are we now guarantee that all
development at simply wedge will be at
least 45 percent affordable
and in carrington 15 affordable
in ratio terms this is a significant
increase on the previous plans
and a step in the right direction it is
also worth saying that as a base level
these developments will be 45 and 15
respectively there is very much scope
and a will to go beyond this where
possible
this administration could not be more
committed to delivering affordable
housing in this borough
i'd just like to tackle the argument
which i'm sure is forthcoming about only
using brownfield land
i hope the leader and executive will
just allow me a small amount of time
to list the brownfield land we have seen
or will see developed
in trafford over the next few years
there are over 14 000 units planned
these include trafford waters
pomona island trafford warside the civic
quarter
the former kellogg site chester house
stratford carrington village pomona
docks
cornbrook works trafford wharf road the
former itron site
trafford plaza seymour grove former bank
mark uk in old trafford
alexander house talbot road in old
trafford
southwest estate regent road car park
the simpsons food factory in ernstein
oakfield road road balmoral road in
orchard
alexandra house in orcharding 319
norwich road in sales stretford memorial
hospital
and the vehicle repair workshop in
stratford
and despite this list on the tory
government figures
we still have a further 21 000 homes to
find under this plan
without gmsf make that 26 000.
the plan for carrington and timperley
wedge is not just about house building
either it's about community building
improved transport links access to job
opportunities
regenerating cell west carrington and
partington and creating jobs
it is about building new schools opening
new health centers
and giving people the opportunity to
live in trafford
the gmsf is a realistic progressive and
forward-thinking plan
to tackle the housing crisis in greater
manchester
it provides trafford with the
opportunity to reduce its housing
numbers
by developing a collaborative approach
there has been a significant reduction
in greenbelt loss from the original plan
in 2016
and this plan enables trafford to play
its part
in improving the chances for everyone
across the convention
i i asked the executive to to approve
the report
thank you leader
thank you councillor right um are there
any members of the
executive who wish to comment on this at
all if you could raise your hand or
indicate in the chat
[Music]
and counselor aunt said please
thank you for yeah uh i'd just like to
uh thank you
for the reply i welcome this strategy
before us today
because it will help to ensure an
end-to-peace meal development
and put into place more rigorous regime
on a whole range of areas
that contained within the document from
leading press and messages
most seems only it focuses purely on
properties that are being built whereas
in fact this is one of the most
important documents that will pass
through
executive and its decisions will help
shape and protect their environment over
the coming decades
from my portfolio perspective i'm really
pleased at the opportunity
to be able to put into place into new
development measures like protected
cycle routes pedestrians and cyclists
to the extent that you cannot simply
achieve the same level when you're
retrofitting
existing communities much of this will
be underpinned by a 2040 transport
strategy
supporting measures to help reduce short
dunes by car
and encouraging actual travel and also
be a real opportunity
to help put into place and achieve
carbon reduction measures for buildings
helping the gm new carbon neutral
strategy
as well to keep it down energy bills
those living and working such
developments
are real and most important to myself
it's options that help support
our biodiversity work the expectation of
the strategy the 10
gain which is something i hope that we
can all fully support with our full and
proper green space just
to help assist with climate change
measures and helping to support
uh reduced flood risk the strategy will
increase piecemeal development
uh with the picking off sites by
developers who really
do not contribute to local
infrastructure
and measures in quite the same way as i
as listed above this strategy will help
ensure
that it does happen as a real
opportunity for homes jobs
thank you leader
thank you counselor i said councillor
patel please
thank you leader i welcome the gmsf as a
once in a lifetime opportunity to plan
strategically on a meaningful city
region scale
when this level of strategic planning is
carried out effectively
it has huge quality of life benefits for
residents
this process has been bogged down by
resistance to defining new green belt
boundaries in
greater manchester something that i
acknowledge as challenging
but that i believe is absolutely the
right thing to do we can haggle about
numbers
empty homes and brownfield first which
is a policy now
but we can't ignore the fact that house
building on a massive scale is required
to address the housing crisis in greater
manchester
the voice missing from this debate
around the gsms
gmsf sorry is one of those in housing
need
they say the political is personal when
it comes to housing it most certainly is
i wager most people who object to the
redefining of the greenback boundary
do so from the comfort of housing
security
the key point i would like to make
however is that the gmsf
is about so much more than that and that
there is a danger that this has been
lost
alongside housing it looks to map
protect and plan around our
environmental assets
employment sites jobs key infrastructure
and transport
within my portfolio the gmsf details
objectives to recognize and enhance
visitor facilities
sporting cultural and heritage assets
and to proactively develop and support
cultural businesses and attractions in
greater manchester towns and cities
having that regional strategy provides a
strong overarching framework to our
local plans and ambitions here in
trafford
i am pleased and delighted to support
this report today
we really need to move this process on
thank you
thank you councillor patel and
councillor carter please
thank you leader i'd like to welcome
this report as well
in greater manchester we want all
children to start school ready to
learn and we want them to enjoy an
education which will help them achieve
things they never thought were possible
we want them to have skills
opportunities and aspirations to
negotiate their future
and the gmsf will help this it will
contribute with
new schools and a high concentration of
knowledge hubs
from ua 92 to the universities
and the research centres and it will
ensure our children young people will be
able to gain the necessary skills to
compete in the fast changing
environments of the future so i would
like to welcome the report
thank you thank you class for carter
councillor slater please
thank you leader um i too would like to
welcome the report
and from my portfolio what i understand
of the gms
gmss objectives or getting teeth back in
is um they will actually promote healthy
and
health health and well-being in our
communities and
it will ensure that the new developments
are properly served by health and care
health care services and will reduce
health impacts
with the work that's going to be done
around air pollution and the
and the issues that and counselor and
ads head has raised around
and changes to and public transport
sustainable travel
cycling walking infrastructure those
those will have
massive benefits for people's health and
well-being and
also the um the gms is seeking to
maximize the health benefits
across and on natural environments and
our great space
and and i understand that the new
developments will lead to a significant
increased
demand and these will be supported by
new improved health facilities and it
will achieve the equality
that is actually needed in our borough
and for our residents to be able to have
access to housing
that is in such short supply currently
thank you leader
yeah thank you um councillor slater i'm
not seeing any other members of the
executive wishing to come in but i know
councillor wright wants to come back on
a
um specific point councillor right
please
thank you leader yes sorry it was remiss
of me to not mention this earlier
um just a few minor changes to the
original document that i just wanted to
um make make members aware of a full
list of these minor changes will be made
available at the time of the
consultation
but for information to know they
currently include
minor typographical corrections to the
text of the gmsf both policy wording and
supporting text
minor corrections to the green belt
boundary including adjacent to a
strategic allocation in stockport
oldham and a green belt edition in wigan
minor graphical changes to maps within
within the document for clarity and
accuracy
a correction to the title of the high
bank meadow allocation in stockport
a correction to the titles of the
greenbelt editions in wigan
corrections to mapping in a number of
the oldham locality assessments
amendment to the statement of
consultation to correct a draft drafting
error
and minor corrections to other
background documents thank you leader
thank you for that um counselor right
um i'll now open up two um
members more widely councillor coggins
please
thank you leader i'll be brief as uh you
said we will have a chance to discuss
this in more detail
and and i want to start by again
thanking all the staff i see adrian
fisher is here and and
all the large number of of his team who
i know across gm have been working on
this for a really
long time i want to also acknowledge the
difficult situation that actually the
administration finds themselves in here
we
realize and the green group has always
realized that um you are having
numbers of housing allocated by
government and
and they're actually working with the
other nine boroughs to share them out to
the
to the gmsf is the right approach and
we've always um disagreed with some of
the plans but always tried to be
authentic and frank in that and and and
tried to ensure that everyone knew what
the accurate information was
so we agree with the principle of
dividing up our allocations across the
ten boroughs
and but obviously we have uh remaining
reservations about what we have come up
with
um i just want to ask tonight about the
last time we discussed this
and in march 2019 we discussed this at
council
and the motion that was finally passed
was the wording of a green amendment
and it said that a new spatial options
paper would be drawn up prioritizing
meeting our carbon budget
and it included talking about air travel
and shipping and notably it said the
traffic council would require
future drafts of the gmsf to follow this
approach
and now as far as i'm aware 18 months on
no new spatial
options paper has been drawn up and this
paper does not follow that approach so
i'm wondering where we stand
and obviously this was an amendment that
was voted through by the labor
administration as well as the green
group and
i'm afraid i can't remember off the top
of my head where the other groups
voted in the end and so
sadly this i think doesn't prioritize
meeting our carbon budget
and instead prioritizes short-term
economic
growth and and i want to acknowledge
some of the arguments we've heard so far
um
i've heard a lot about housing needs
tonight
but unfortunately there's no guarantee
that actually the affordable homes that
we need
are going to come out of this and like
the rest of the planning system the
government has set this up to be a way
that allows
developers to carve up the countryside
building houses that normal families
can't afford to live in
and and we have to remember that climate
justice is social justice
we can't prioritize the housing need
just of those in trafford and ignore
the huge implications that the climate
crisis is causing for housing
for people all across the world and and
for people closer to home
between flooding and even we now have
have local fires
so i'm really i suppose asking for an
update on
how you can square this with what the
labor administration voted through
in 2019 thank you
thank you i'll bring councillor writing
and then perhaps richard also just to
um clarify on that also councillor right
yeah um thank you um councillor coggins
i think there are a number of positive
green measures in this document to be
perfectly honest but for more detail i'm
going to pass over to richard on that
point
just in relation to um the affordable
homes comment that you made
we are guaranteeing 45 of the simply
allocation
will be affordable homes that is a
significant amount of affordable homes
in one of the most expensive areas of
the borough and in fact one of the most
expensive areas of greater manchester
um that is beyond where we were a couple
of years ago
in this in this area and i think it's
safe to say that this administration is
very committed
to making sure that we have a number of
affordable homes built in this borough
um as you all have noticed noticed that
we have
just we are currently in the middle of
building um
30 social homes in simply um
and they are the first social homes to
be built in traffic in a very very long
time
um and that is just the start of it
through the affordable housing fund so
i don't think you need to be concerned
about uh this administration
um pushing forward the affordable
housing agenda i think it's safe to say
that we're very much on top of that
but i'll come come just pass over to
richard on the on the points that you
make about
the greens thank you
thanks james i think as you said in your
introduction the paper
the gmsf sets out a commitment to gm
being carbon neutral by 2038 and by
development through the gmsf of itself
being carbon neutral by 2028
i think that fully complies with the uh
the requirements
of the paper to meet the the council's
green
agenda um there are other details in
return
in relation to the motion to council uh
councillor cochrane i'm aware that have
been raised that we will check
and we'll we'll come back on separately
prior to
the discussed at full council
thank you um richard thank you james i
will
come next to other leaders councilor
evans
please
thank you chair i appreciate that and
and in line with their
uh cat counselor uh coggins i'll i'll
respect that this
is not a debate tonight and it is for
comment and probably genuine questions
and but having said that i wish you to
share that with your group because
councillor wright launched in what into
what could only describe as an opening
portion of the whole debate but we'll
let that go and
so to be clear this is this well i'll
let it go council lawrence because i
chair the meeting and the voting members
of the executive
can present their papers as they see fit
they are voting members
you are here effectively as an observer
and i am allowing you the right to ask
questions please proceed
all right so kind counselor western so
thank you um
so to be clear this is a labor gmsf
it's been bought brought together by the
gmca
which when it was conceived many years
ago was dominated
90 labor and is currently 91
labor so let us be really clear who is
creating
this gmsf but the question is and the
genuine question is
should stop port and i appreciate
they're in the process of trying to get
some back
back room deals to get this over the
line which should
stop or turn this down will we bring it
be bringing it to council at the end of
the month
and if we are how how can it be valid
well clearly chancellor evans we can't
speculate on what may or may not happen
in stockport but obviously all um boris
would be required to
approve the gmsf i'm not sure if jane
lefevre is on the call and wants to
clarify specifically but certainly if
it's unable to pass through stockport
then i'd be very keen that the the other
nine boroughs work together to attempt
to
um retain the the ability to
share the need amongst the nine that's
required but jane do you want to
consider the specifics
of what would happen were this to fall
in stockport please
i'm just trying to
yes there we are right um so if the
position is
as it stands that the gms is supposed to
be a document that is supported by all
ten
um authorities um i think addition would
have
reviewed in the event that it failed in
stockport um to give the opportunity for
other councils
to consider the position at that point
as i understand it
um richard may also
have some information on that um this is
a
quite a complex matter
it's taken a long time to to get to this
point and it has depended very much upon
the cooperation of all groups at this
stage
um but as you say i think it's not
appropriate to consider what may or may
not happen
at some uh future point but at the
moment um i know that it has
uh passed earlier today in thames side
and
um when discussed previously um it has
been on the basis that uh there is still
um
support across the ten authorities for
proceeding
with this uh document thank you
thanks jane and we will of course keep
all members updated us to
um progress appreciating that stockport
in particular
um is challenging okay and um on that
basis of coming to leaders
first i think um councillor new gross
was waving earlier do you want to come
in julian
thank you very much chair i appreciate
that um so i have a
general question here uh thank you can i
ask thank you the officers for the
briefing they gave
one key point was the 15
685
allocation of houses already available
in the urban
area in the coming years plus a possible
777
giving us about 16 and a half thousand
my question is how many years supply
have we got available to us before we
have to go and destroy the green belt
and build on that
um that's my first question and um
i'll have a follow-up if that's possible
um after that so it's really for adrian
to uh
i think possibly or well mr ryan adrian
do you want to want
to come in on that specific question
around supply
uh yes uh thank you leader um uh yeah
you you're correct
i mean the vast majority are
roughly at least three-quarters of our
housing need
we estimate can be met from sites that
are within the urban area
um but the difficulty is that not all of
them
are going to be available all at once
and this plan looks ahead to
um the period 20 through to 2037
and so we have to consider a housing
need right across the plan period
um and make sure we have provision for
all that time uh and so if a change is
necessary
in other words if we can't as this is
the position we can't accommodate
everything in the urban area
we have to address that at this point so
that's why
notwithstanding that the bulk can be
accommodated within the urban area
we need to address the point about the
remainder
at this stage because it is a plan
um that we approve now for the next 17
years
thank you leader thanks eddie and julian
did you want to clarify anything based
on that
um it was also possibly have we
have we paused to reconsider our
business
office requirements in this plan
postcovid
councillor wright do you want to comment
on that
yeah we have reviewed that of course
because kobe has had a significant
impact on that but
um i think it's so to say that we um
we are going to need um the employment
uh land going forward and and you will
note that the majority of the
employment land in carrington for
example is not going to be office based
it's going to be manufacturing based
um so it wouldn't necessarily have the
same impact as as office based
buildings i don't know whether either of
the offices wanted to comment on that
further but
um my understanding would be that we
have considered it
and of course it wouldn't necessarily be
dominated by office
space thank you thanks
councillor right um richard do you want
to add anything on that
no i think as council wright said we
have considered it
i think when we're looking at a very
long time frame here across
17 years what we would expect is office
demand to change
across that period of time so whilst we
should
take account of the effect of covid we
shouldn't be entirely bound by making
assumptions about what might happen in
the future based
on the effect that we've seen over the
last nine to ten
ten months don't know adrian if there's
anything you want to add
um thank you i think the only thing i'd
add is that already that there has been
quite a consistent trend for
um uh residential conversion of of of
office accommodation so so we already
have
quite a lot of that both uh approved but
also in the pipeline
so um so that's something to be mindful
of that that is already an important
contributor
to our brownfield supply
thank you um richard adrian um okay
moving on could we go
to um councillor holden who has a
question please okay can you all hear me
now
um yeah first of all before i raise
any questions on this i must apologize
for councillor wright for making these
deals and comments
first of all a language
he referred to this at the beginning as
a final
draft i thought you were having a
consultation
process but i mentioned that my name is
understood
that we all appreciate i can be a very
good way
the other concern that i have is i'm
looking at the map
on the second screen of the allocation
around currency
how confident is
that you can protect the green belt
which is owned by highway
to the north of western ways the born
and boulevard or whatever
every road is going to be called to the
point where it
meets the existing world
i'm sure that the owners and the
developers will have their eye on that
might be really
comfortable if you determine you can
protect that and the other
is the funding for schools
have you received any sort of
reassurance
that we will be able to get our hands on
sufficient from
for both primary and secondary school
allocation within this even within this
modification
thank you thank you
councillor holden the um the background
noise that
made that a little challenging at times
i'm not sure if that's just my line but
i think we
i think we were able to to get that so
counselor right you want to
um come back on that yeah i think
i think i understood most of it um so i
i i refer to it as the final draft
councillor holden so
uh prior to consultation not the final
plan um so obviously it's a final draft
with further consultation
that will um that will um bring about
the
the final plan um the i think yeah i
think i heard you refer to the route of
the road in carrington
um i think i think that's what i heard
but it was very difficult to understand
um the route of the road uh or the
potential currency and relief thread
hasn't been designed yet
uh and will of course go out to
consultation uh before any route
is um agreed upon so um with
that that can be discussed at that point
really there hasn't been an agreed route
as things stand
um and um just in relation to the
education
funding aspect um i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna try and uh lie
about being an expert on that so i'm
gonna go to
an officer to ask that question but or
maybe one of my colleagues who may be
able to help me with that
if that's okay um adrian richard
uh thanks james i'll let adrian come in
on the
education point but i think if i if i
heard correctly council holder the query
was around the protection of the green
belt
the land that's returned within green
belt to the north
of the north of the road and our
confidence in being able to return that
in in greenbelt
and i think as was said earlier that
though one of the basis of the plan
is that by managing the control of the
release of greenbelt
it gives us greater certainty about the
protection of the land that is held
within
the greenbelt plus the gmsf because it
gives it ensures that we've got a supply
of land to meet development which means
we can manage and resist
speculatively development on greenbelt
it also minimizes as far as we can
within the housing needs assessment the
amount of land that the council needs to
make available for housing
development so i think puts us in the
best position to protecting ourselves
against any potential future incursion
into
uh into greenbelt um
i'll pass over to adrian in terms of the
specific point around education
contributions
yeah thank you richard um yeah so um the
policies that allocate land at both
temporally and
uh carrington uh have within them uh
proposals around education so in some
cases that may include
uh the site of a new primary school um
but but certainly it will cover
education provision um and uh within
uh the planning system there is uh a
mechanism by which
uh proportion of contributions can be
sought from
new developments to cover the cost of
education where there is a local
shortfall
so those are all embodied in the plan
and that
will provide a means by which those
developments will
as i say pay proportionately towards
their educational impact
thank you
thank you um adrian richard um
councillor jerome please thanks
um i just wanted to make the point that
i think if i'm right
typically wedge is in a hot market
location
in hot market conditions under our l7
core strategy
and that says that the minimum
requirement is 45
so all this gms f iteration is doing is
make it
making it policy compliant with trafford
but one thing i've noticed if you take
the two green belt areas together
carrington moss and timply wedge
carrington moss is
much bigger in terms of the houses it it
has a plan
for but that's coming down by 15 in
terms of its affordable housing
requirement and if you take the two
areas together the overall
affordable housing is actually coming
down in this iteration of the
gmsf is that not a little bit of a worry
counselor right please
uh you're right to say that the simply
wedge allocation is policy compliant
um as i think i said to you councillor
jerome earlier in the
um my presentation was that uh this is
the minimum
requirement they would be seeking for in
these locations
and of course this administration will
always strive to
go beyond that level of affordable
housing uh wherever possible
um but what we've got to be realistic
about is we need development of all
kinds
in trafford we need um we need
owner-occupied homes we need privately
rented homes we need social housing
we need all types of mixes of tenure to
tackle the housing crisis
but of course i can assure you that we
will be
aiming to get as much affordable housing
out of this scheme as we possibly can
just in relation to the numbers um on
the affordable housing that you raised
my understanding that there it hasn't
been a reduction in affordable units
i am as part of this i mean the the
ratio
doesn't suggest that but um i don't have
the don't have the exact numbers to
handle this second i'm more than happy
to try and come back to you in a couple
of minutes on that unless
one of the officers wants to come in uh
this moment in time thanks james
richard are you able to clarify or if
not we'll get an answer to
councillor jerome outside of the meeting
i think in terms of what they allocate
um the current rate for uh current as we
we will
confirm i would just note that in
simply wedge that's an assessment based
on a hot market in a hot market
location and therefore that designation
of
whether we're in a hot market or not may
change depending on the
on the market and they are also subject
to
uh viability tests so in every in every
case it's subject to a viability test
effectively through the gmsf
certainly for currents and what we've
done is that viability test is being
done
prior to the development taking place
which is why we've got the figure
there based on the work that's won by
the three dragons
thank you so we'll follow up on the
specific numbers
around carrington if that's okay for you
to take away james and richard
um counselor miss blackburn please
thank you leader um i wanted to um
ask a question with regards to flood
risk
um homes built on the flood risk sites
are less likely in the future to be
allowed insurance
and if that's the case would
same people want to live in an area that
is more likely to be flooded um
people need homes people deserve homes
we all
we all want that but i thought my
concern is that
um if if if properties are are built in
these sort of um
areas that might be flooded um
are we are we sort of making the right
choices
for future residents and also
secondly um if
if we've got sort of flood
mitigation will that be done by by
trafford or would it be
in the hands of the environment agency
thank you thank you
um counselor right do you want to come
in on that and then i suspect we may
have some technical clarification from
richard or adrian
yeah uh thank you council doctor i would
like to speculate on
uh whether people would like to buy a
house on a floodplain particularly
because that would
wouldn't be my part to do but i mean
what i would say is that every
development will have
a flood risk assessment as part of any
planning application
um so uh clearly that would need to be
satisfactory
and um and sound going forward but
rather than me i'm trying to go into the
planning technicalities i'll bring in
one of the experts if that's okay who
may be able to clarify it further
richard or adrian adrian uh
thank you leader um yes just to say that
um
on the front um uh of the uh
report you'll see links through to um
both the gms gmsf document and also the
list of supporting documents
and if you then delve further into those
links you'll find
well a huge number of documents but
amongst those is a strategic flood risk
assessment
so part of the underpinning of this plan
is quite a lot of work at the high level
around
flood assessment flood risk and that
will also feed into
some of the other supporting assessments
around site suitability
but then as a council rights alluded to
when we get to the planning application
stage
then equally there is a further detailed
piece of work
that will be required um in support of
any planning application which would
also be required
on all of these allocations thank you
thank you um yeah go ahead castle on the
smackdown would you just ask
um then would for to do with flood
litigation would it be trafford or it be
the environment agency who would be
ultimately responsible
for prevention of any disaster
adrian um it would the the
environment agency would uh advise
uh on that but the the planning decision
so in other words the decision
uh as to whether homes go ahead in a
particular location
what would be ours as the planning
authority but the environment agency
would very much be part of um
of that decision um and of course some
some of these you know in certain terms
of the bigger picture then the
environment
agency very much has a role and have
been involved in the preparation
of the plan um so there are some
strategic interventions
across the whole of the the network for
which they would be responsible
thank you thank you thanks adrian and
um councillor welton please
thank you leader um i just couldn't that
was a very impressive list
read out by uh councillor wright uh of
um
potential developments um i couldn't
help noticing that i think that the all
tear one was missing
um from that one and i just wondering if
he could if he can appreciate that it's
quite a hard
sell locally um regarding building on
the green belt when a development like
that
has lain in stasis for so long
thank you that's the right
[Music]
uh yes i think we've had we think we've
had this conversation publicly and
privately before councillor welton that
of course as a local authority we are
disappointed as things stand that altair
hasn't come
forward as yet um i can can
categorically say that we are pushing
the developer
to make sure that this this comes
forward as soon as possible
thank you thank you
um i think that's everybody who has
indicated
to speak on this item um so with that
i will move the recommendations i set
out
at page one of the report can they be
approved
please
thank you okay moving on then
and um item four is the approval to
consult on the all age travel assistance
policy
um 2021-22 councillor heinz please
thank you very much leader um so the
council has a statutory
duty to review its travel arrangements
costs and charges and eligibility for
travel assistance and i bring this
report to the executive to consider
a proposal to go out to consultation on
removing the discretionary criteria
of the all-age transport policy and
that provides travel assistance to
pupils traveling
to attend a grammar school i will
explain
the report and the proposals in a few
moments but i do want to set this within
um the context in which it's being
proposed
um and i also want to offer some
assurances really that the proposal
won't impact low-income families who
meet the criteria
for free school meals and i do stress
that this is to go out to
consultation and that we do want to
understand the views of residents and
we'll take these into account
when making any final decisions um
and the proposal will be subject to an
equality
impact assessment um sadly
as a direct consequence of the ongoing
impacts of coronavirus
um on the council's finances the council
is facing the most
difficult decisions um related to its
budget that it's ever
really had to to make and with the
shortfall of 37 million pounds
in next year's budget um we do know that
we will need to make some incredibly
difficult decisions um and it's within
that context that i bring the report to
the executive
this evening um to further set this
particular proposal
into a financial context and
it's also important to understand um
that the council
is forecast to spend 4.5 million pounds
um in 2021
um on transport and travel assistance
and and it's proposed that this policy
change
would take effect in september next
year and that the projected saving
um for next year would be 30 000
pounds and that this will increase um
to um a saving of 45 000
pounds in the following year and i want
to stress that the proposals
again stress that the proposals won't um
impact um those lowest
income families and it also won't
impact um the council's statutory
obligations regarding transport and
travel assistance
um in any way and to explain that
within the home to school travel and
transport statutory guidance
and the nearest qualifying school is the
school
nearest the child's home that has the
places available
that provide an education appropriate to
the age and ability
of the child and also any special
educational needs that the child may
have
if a parent chooses a more distant
school
travel assistance will not be provided
unless the extended
rights apply which is in relation to
low-income families the council will
continue
to meet all of those statutory
requirements
but within trafford's current policy
there is an additional
discretionary criterion which provides
travel assistance to children to attend
the nearest grammar school
for which they're eligible and even if
it's not the nearest qualifying school
and the proposal this evening is to
remove this discretionary
criteria and this would mean that if a
child chooses to travel
or if a parent chooses for their child
to travel to access the grammar school
place then they'll need to cover the
cost
of um the travel and there are currently
120 children who benefit from this
scheme and the savings of the council
um as i said earlier in time will be 45
000 pounds a year and the report details
the proposal further and provides the
time frame for the consultation
um and i submit it to the executive
um for consideration thanks leader
thank you um councillor heinz just
before we
um move on to any questions or comments
if i can ask
um counselor asshair council weapons
council ms blackburn just to lower your
hands just so that i know if you want to
come back in
it is on this item please um are there
any questions
or comments from members of the
executive
on this item at all
no and any questions or comments more
widely
i'll bring councilman blackburn straight
in
thank you leader um if i could ask the
exec member just to clarify something
um could if if um if
places are taken by out of borough
children and those um are the schools
nearest to
uh you know a border with another
authority
and our children who live in trafford
can't go to the nearest grammar school
then
are they are they sort of not
not not sort of allowed to to to claim
the extra travel um allowance could you
just clarify
um so so my understanding is
if um a child would be traveling
um further than the nearest qualifying
school then no they won't be able to
claim the um the the travel
assistance even if even if
they'd apply to that school maybe pass
but maybe the places were taken because
possibly they were allocated to out of
out of borough
um applicants i mean i i think that's a
difficult that would be a difficult
situation to assess because
if they are eligible um and by being
eligible that means that you have been
offered a place at the the grammar
school and
then you know that's the place that you
would access so if you're not eligible
because you've not been offered the
place
then you know it would be the case that
that this
policy would um would kick in at that
point if that makes sense
yeah i think i think if if the child say
um
they applied to say three or four
different schools
and they're only offered a place
as a school further away
and maybe because they haven't haven't
been accepted at the nearest grammar
school
again that that would that that would be
a no to applying for the help with
with the transport costs yes it would
okay thank you thank you
are there any further questions or
comments on this i think councillor
holden
may have indicated yes thank you leader
i changed my sound system
much better
media city has nothing on my upstairs
bedroom it really doesn't
um little nervous here as you might
expect me to be
i represent an area where
often in fact one might say
frequently pupils are dispatched
to secondary schools some considerable
distance away
because their local school is filled by
the sort of
numbers that linda blackburn was talking
about the
out of the area and so on
i am slightly reassured by the
allowances for disadvantaged children
i would like though just to put on
record the fact that as we go through
this conversation
i will continue to highlight that it
appears
i may be wrong but it appears to me that
this is targeted
specifically at parents
who dare to choose a grammar school
which is further away than their nearest
school
now please just reassure me that i'm
wrong in that assumption
thank you
yeah i mean that is absolutely not the
intention
at all councillor holden and the you
know we do want to go out to
consult on this and hear people's views
and it
it isn't um to discriminate at all
um it is around the um the discretionary
uh criteria um and we will be listening
to
people's views and taking those into
account um
and it absolutely is not intended to
um to put anybody into any hardship
thank you um sorry jill i think your
hand went up and came down did you want
to come in on the
on this at all it was just to say that
actually
in terms of how places are allocated at
the grammar schools
it is allocated in terms of ability
in the school's discretion so it isn't
that
potentially children or pupils from
outer borough are being prioritized
above our own
so even though somebody might have
passed
an examination the school will still
prioritize
in terms of if they have more pupils
that have actually
passed a level in terms of the
allocation of places but in terms of the
specifics that was asked
we'll come back with a level of detail
in order to clarify the issue
that would be helpful thank you and i
can't see
anybody else looking to come in on this
item so um the recommendations basically
to go out to consort on this proposal
are us set out on the cover page of the
report
um all in favor aye
thank you um there being no items
of urgent business
we can bring the meeting to a close so
thank you very much
everybody for your attendance um and see
you all soon
thank you thank you